e
okay we'll open up the exec section oh I
don't have my gavel
so um so I guess uh just make some
announcements so that people who are
here might not need to be here there
were some bills that we had already exec
and taken care of and sent even to the
floor or whatever and that they still
showed up on the list and those
bills um we will not be taking action
again having said that um there there
are bills that are on the list that um
still need their amendments drawn up and
that would be uh 1241 money transmitters
1129 uh proxy voting by condo
associations um 1365 biological products
by
pharmacies uh 1227 relative extending
the hours of alcohol beverage sales for
licenses uh 1358 relative to contract
manufacturers of beer and wine and
liquor
okay what
happened
1227 yeah extending the hours what did
what did we end up doing with that
one we just ought to pass with it okay
so that one will that will just be out
to
pass these are bills that you're waiting
on the amendment those those are the
Bills we're waiting on an amendment and
where are the amendments are they so
legislative
Services no it's not like they've drawn
they're not done yet they have not
they've all been requested they all been
requested it's just just some they
didn't happen yeah
okay we're waiting we're not today that
is correct okay so I'm about to
finish I stand I haven't finished yet
okay so everybody understands what we're
doing here today we're going to be doing
just uh what we can get done so if
something is not correct not right or we
have you know
uh some different reflection on what we
should do anything that's a problem we
are not going to take action on it today
okay and then we have a subcommittee
this afternoon and then next week um
Tuesday every bill that's laying around
is going to get on the calendar now
there might be a bill that did get it
did get exec by its subcommittee but
we're it's on there just to make sure we
don't forget it and make sure we got
everything all our ducks in a row and
then on Wednesday at 10:00 we'll have
the final exec
session everything has to be out of
committee technically Thursday but
Thursday is a session so we're not going
to be able to do it then so what my
expectation is is that um we'll we'll at
10:00 there could be some bills that
held over from Tuesday and we'll we'll
you know insert them in maybe U you know
Wednesday morning but um at the end of
the day we're Wednesday we will um we
have to exec everything everything has
to be out of committee by Wednesday okay
now you have any more questions
representa
M I'm not sure we all I don't know if I
got all the bills that not doing today I
got does it matter we get there and I
say we're not doing it doesn't matter
you really need to know I was this
wasn't for you cuz you're not I expect
you to stay in your seat this was for
somebody he was in the room waiting for
that bill that we're not going to take
up that was who what that speech was for
excuse me Mr chairman yes I seem to have
missed the the um uh email notice which
subcommittee is this
afternoon the uh I think it's a mixed
bag I do you have me have the
list it's a little it's a little bit of
everything I think I see all right thank
you
okay so um the money transmitters
amendment is not done yet so we will not
take that up yet next is
uh House Bill 1444 uh relative to local
regulation of digital
Cole we read
thebody okay I don't know we go so um
evidently I in the old days where we
used to have all the stuff pil in here
uh evidently that was banned um but I
did get special dispensation to allow
that to be in the room so I will I will
go get
it
the original voting committee was six to
study
okay
okay Mr chairman I can answer that one
okay great it was six to nothing inter
room study
okay
1444 all right thank you you're welcome
represent Cole seconded by
representative burrows for interim study
any discussion on the motion
seeing
yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes pelli yes
Axton Lily what was was
yes Burrows
yes Herbert
yes clerk yes melier yes
Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan
yes and uh Jack
yes and um chairman hunt
yes all right
unanimous you votes
no oh sorry yes on inter study yes oh
there it is you vote no no he votes yes
oh okay see what happens when you think
you're being
him okay all those in favor of placing
um House Bill 1444 on the consent
Calendar please say I that was opposed
so moved
unanimously 18 to
zip right because it was still so that's
right have Terry and who else is are you
feeling from grass he's feeling from
to 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 I just counted 18 one two three four
five six seven eight nine 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17
18 okay every in room how many people
here
okay Vincent and missing Vincent Terry
and we're missing Terry so that was were
the two that was the the two
yeah no it just what was misleading is
that how somehow we filled it all in
comfortably and so you you don't really
feel the the fact that people are
missing their names are not on here
either and their names are not on there
there we go all
right get through that 20
minutes okay all right house bill
1507 Financial
Services um like to make a motion okay
Cole okay great HB 1507 was also six to
nothing recommended by committee and
seconded by representative
spear
okay so the motion is inexpedient to uh
stud 4an slip
right okay any discussion on the motion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
an interim study got
it representative Ammon yes Tusk yes
post yes Cole yes mchu
yes pelli yes Walsh yes zon yes Barrow
yes Herbert
yes L yes
melier yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear
yes
Sullivan Jack yes and chairman hunt yes
18 the vot is 18 to zip all those in
favor of consent please say I I those
opposed moved
cold
okay next up 1537 relative to credit
card
notifications
and
motion I'd be happy to make a motion Mr
chairman repres M leader you
make okay all right so representative Ms
would like to do do it I thought he just
made the motion I know I was make sure
he was awake show the m and mever okay
let's take with macul yes Maul is
great and mchu and uh second by
better that's why you want to do
everything in
pencil I'm following that sheet okay
that's
fine but the problem with this was we
didn't have too many Democrats because
we were only Republicans in the room
okay all right so motion is inexpedient
to legislate any uh discussion on the
motion seeing
none clerk will call the role on
inexpedient to
legislate representative Ammon yes pusk
yes poost yes Cole yes McHugh yes belli
yes Daxton yes Walsh yes
yes Herbert yes cler yes Maier yes cabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes and
chairman hunt yes and Jack votes yes
oh got
it okay now the vote is 18 to Z all
those in favor placing on the consent
calender please say I I those opposed so
moved
unanimously okay 15
Michael any in being to legislate yep
MCU okay any discussion on the motion of
inexpedient to
legislate seeing none the clerk will
call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes McHugh yes belli yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert
yes clerk yes M yes collabro yes Gibbs
yes spear yes
elivan Jack
yes and chairman hunt yes 18 okay all
those in favor placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed
s okay 1559 roaling the chapter relative
to cash dispensing machines
representative hunt seconded by
representative mcul moves a to pass any
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the rooll ought to pass not to pass
okay love repealing
1559 representative Ammon yes pusk yes
po yes o yes mugh yes belli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes maer yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes Jack
yes and chairman hunt yes 180
uh the vote is 18 to zip all those in
favor of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay HB 1694 relative to
establishing committee to study New
Bank
M Lita do you want to take this one or
you want me to take it we're doing it
169 okay representative burough seconded
by
representative Ammon moves uh itl on
House Bill
1694 is there any discussion on the
motion
seeing none the clerk will call the role
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes mugh yes melli yes Daxton
no clerk yes M yes cabro no I mean yes
sorry yes yes
yes
spear yes Sullivan yes Jack
yes and representative yes uh
representative Herbert do you have a
calendar okay all those all those favor
of the consent Calendar please say I
those
oppose
so so it's Burrows is the uh making the
yes okay uh House Bill 1129 relative to
the authority to vote by proxy in a
condomini oh that we still need
Amendment on that one okay 11 House Bill
1127 relative to the meetings of
condominium boards and
committees uh this one is was ought to
pass and I have representative Ammon
made the motion
you don't right I well I had 1172 as
really it's OTP it's
OTP what what what did this one do
repres okay so right now the motion is
uh representative Burrows oh was 5 days
versus 10
days giving a notice of 5 dayss noce it
was moving out the notice date yeah from
5 to 10 okay all right so who wants to
okay to pass to pass motion was out to
pass
and I'm sorry I gave misinformation last
night
fine ought to pass ought to pass okay
so so this was all this bill did was
move the meeting meeting notice from
five days to 10
days the other way around excuse me
question is on
app they can post the schedule in
advance yeah it was from 10 days to five
days 10 days all right it shortens the
time yeah represent M you Mr chairman
line seven a meeting of the board of
directors shall not include
informational sessions
held by board members to obtain and
compare vendor
proposers uh proposals including but not
limit to Landscaping Lawn Care snow
removal septic services wealth Services
Insurance window cleaning and common
area maintenance provided that the
review and vote on any motions resulting
from the informational session so it's
excluding those informational
sessions from these meetings I'm not
sure what the committee feels about that
I'm just poting out those are things
that the the board should not need to
have a time frame in which to to have
those discussions I don't particularly
have an opinion on it I'm just pointing
out that it does more than just the
notice okay I don't know what the
committee thinks but any other concerns
about
the I had down on my notes it kind of
came down to the urgency if there was
something that they needed to deal with
five days notice would be a lot better
window if they had an emergency rather
than 10 days notice that's kind of what
it came down to and and we also had
words that said that um uh they can post
information long in advance of the
meeting so anyways
right okay so the motion the pending
motion is ought to pass any more
discussion on the motion of about to
pass seeing none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes mugh yes pelli yes d
yes Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
Clark yes AER
yes labro yes hibs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes jimon hunt yes 18 Z
okay 18 to zip all those in favor
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so move
damous okay House Bill
1224 now this one I have inexperience to
legislate by representative
itl I guess I'm read the
thing you want to speak to your
motion one sec otherwise we can just go
vot oh gosh yes
okay okay any more discussion on the
motion of housef
1224 that was a good speech seeing n the
clerk will call the
rooll representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole
yes yes melli yes Axton balsh yes burrow
yes Herbert
yes clerk yes maer yes cabro yes Gibbs
yes
spear yes Sullivan yes Jack yes and
chairman hunt
yes 18 Z all those in favor of placing
on the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so moov
nously okay next up HB 1306 I have have
in my notes now uh the motion was
interim study moved by representative
Ammon and second by representative
Herbert
1306 I'm not
even this
1306 well no that sheet I could be wrong
I could have been I could have been
wrong on my notes it is that's what we
thought sub committee interim study
interim study wait
this was the one how to um well one is
the board the board should be doing a
better job in doing in reserving money
for Capital Improvements but I I think
we we according to my notes we had a
hard time figuring out what this bill
meant and put it on inum study in order
to give anybody some time to go figure
out what it was asking for okay all
I make the motion right right it makes
an interim study motion second might
yes
okay interim study any discussion on the
motion of interim
study all right see none the clerk will
call the
role representative Ammon yes pusic yes
post yes po
yes yes pelli yes baxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yes Clark yes mle
yes labro yes
Gibbs
yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack
yes and chairman
hunt yes 180 vote is 18 to zero all
those in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say up hi hi those
unly okay all right so I'll do is I'll
read my notes and then we can take it
from there all right so 1357 relative to
condominium board
meetings so my notes show that it was
inexpedient to legislate moved by
representative
Herbert is that what everybody else's
note
show represent Herbert are you ready to
make that motion yes sir okay second by
represent Ammon is 1357 inexpedient to
legislate is there any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
OST yes Cole yes Miku yes yes Chell yes
Daxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes maer yes cabro yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan Jack yes chamman
hunt
yes
okay 18 to zip um all those in favor of
consent please say I those
opposed so move
dly okay we're out of banking and
condos
on
Insurance House Bill 18 1081 relative
insurance payments to ambulance
providers representative hunt second by
representative buroughs moves ought to
pass on 1081 on 1081
you you want to write the blur but I'll
tell you I I'm I'm having the blur
written up for me because uh what I want
everyone to know and certainly I know
there's people in the audience who care
very much about how this is how this is
going down is that what the issue is
that ambulances or either if they're a
if they're in network or not have not
signed a network contract so what we're
going to say is that in either case the
insurance company uh will send the check
directly to the ambulance company
however that differential between
whether they're in network whether they
have a contract or not will be a um that
would be determined by the insurance
company as terms of what they're going
to send that check is going to be um and
the caveat is that um if if so if a uh
an ambulance is has not signed a
contract is not in the network
um is going to get a check that's going
to be theoretically lower than the check
they would have gotten if they did sign
a contract they still will be allowed to
balance
Bill and we're going to write this in
the blur so that everybody knows balance
disappearing yes I have in my notes that
it needs an amendment so can we clarify
that please so we were going to we were
trying to think that we need whether we
need to write this in the amendment and
we don't need to it's just going to be
in the blurb and that
has that that has the intent of the
legislation we don't we didn't need to
clarify this we you know in terms of
situation
okay and I think all parties are happy
resolution put it away neither side is
is
estatic because this is a
compromise okay so the uh motion is
ought to
pass is the question clear the clerk
will call the role representative Ammon
yes pusk yes poost yes Cole yes mugh yes
belli yes Axton yes Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes clerk yes maer
yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Z all those in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so moved
unanimously okay 1094 relative to
insurance coverage for Pediatric
autoimmune neuros psychiatric
disorders can't believe I got through
that okay and representative pelli
second by
representative Burrows uh moves
inexpedient to legislate uh the sponsor
asked us to dispose of the
bill is there any discussion on the
legislate all right seeing none the
ready
representative Ammon yes pusk yes o yes
Cole yes mugh
yes pelli yes Daxton Walsh yes Burrows
yes Herbert yes clerk yes mle yes cabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes
Jack yes and chairman hunt
yes 18 to zero vote is 18 to zip um all
those in favor of placing on the consent
Calendar please say I I those opposed so
move moved
unanimously okay House Bill 1236
relative to the repealing the commission
on the status of health coverage markets
for individuals and small employers
representive hunt seconded by
representative burough moves to
pass
statute any other discussion on the
motion seeing none the clerk will call
ready representative Ammon yes ausk yes
poost yes Cole yes G yes pelli yes
taxton Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes collabro yes Gibbs yes
spear
yes
Sullivan Jack yes chairman hunt yes 18 Z
okay the vote is 18 zip all those in
favor of the putting on the consent
Calendar please say I those opposed so
moved
unanimously
okay uh house build 1296 relative to
insurance coverage for Diagnostic and
supplemental breast
examinations uh I have the
representative
burrow pass OTP yeahp oh actually I I
want to have a little something to do
with the blurb and making it clear what
what we're doing in yeah I a blur breast
oh you do have breast okay
yeah
what okay fine representative burrow
second by representative
H and just be aware that I might be
body okay representative peros do you
want to speak to your motion um yes um
this bill is relative to coverage for
Diagnostic and supplemental breast exams
we're moving uh OTP because uh we feel
that this is essential to women's
healthare and will actually reduce costs
yeah yes Heidi you have to come up and
mic
good morning Mr chairman I'm sorry to
interrupt your executive uh session I
just wanted to mention that the
effective date with mandates we
typically try to have those be January
1st of whatever the upcoming year is so
I was wondering if that effective date
could be what is the effective date the
effective date I believe as drafted was
60 days after passage rather than
January 1 we don't want that J rather
than January 1st of 2025 okay so why
don't we put this off to next week and
then and we'll get that done
okay so uh you're okay with withdrawing
your motion yes I withdraw my motion
okay thank you all right uh next up how
chairman hun yes I had that it needed a
fiscal note is that not true anymore so
fiscal notes is something that really
has to happen before the process begins
and it's really a decision of the
department that that the legislation
would be referred to to generate that
fiscal Noe okay that in this case it
would say that there really is no direct
expense to um to taxpayers that it would
only uh it's only potential expense is
going to be into to Insurance um if we
decided that that was going to be a very
dramatic effect that that really has
effect we do have the right to interim
study the bill and send it to the
insurance department to have them do a
fiscal study which does cost money to do
that study but that would study would
then come back with what their analysis
of what the long-term impact the cost
being okay thank
you okay so we'll move on to the next
one
um we're not we're not going to exect
this today 1225 all right so next is
1225 rela to prescription drug
affordability board conflicts of
interest um I have here the
representative hunt seconded by
study any discussion on the motion of
interim
study all
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes Daxton
Walsh yes burrow yes berbert yes clerk
yes M yes cabro yes Gibbs yes Bear yes
Sullivan Jack yes jamman hunt yes 18
Z in study okay all those in favor of
placing the bill on the consent Calendar
please say I I those opposed so mov
unanimously okay 1365 the amendment is
not done
yet next up is House Bill
1571 uh relative to requiring insurance
coverage for glucose monitoring devices
for people with
diabetes so I have here is that we is
interim
Burrows uh question yes weren't we
supposed to be getting back a mandated
study from the insurance company as to
what this would cost okay that's right
you're right so that this bill this
interim study that in the blurb will
mention that this will be going to the
insurance department to do a financial
analysis okay much which I had just
ago
yeah thank you for reminding
me okay is the motion clear interim
study the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Co yes a yes belli yes Daxton
Walsh yes burrow yes
Herbert yes clerk yes M yes Calabro yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes Jack
yes chairman hunt yes 18 Z okay vote is
18 Z can I just clarify we are going to
really work on that with the with the
the department has to yeah do that
analysis yeah
perfect but it is true that that you
know that analysis will be do they're
doing that over the summer so this will
be you know whe where we get it in time
for to make a recommend for future
legislation but nothing it would have to
come in as a separate bill next
session okay of all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so moved
unanimously okay 1155 relative to
insurance cover for living organ
donors
uh I have I have uh you cared about this
bill it was OTP right okay Mr chairman
MCU second by represent buo uh M ought
0885 is there any discussion on the
motion of a to pass on the
amendment
seeing none the clerk will call the role
amendment all right representative Ammon
yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes
belli yes axon yes Walsh
yes Burrows yes Herbert yes Clerk yes
mle yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes jamman hunt yes 18 Z
okay the vote passes 18 to zip now
represent MCU second by representative
buo moves ought to pass as amended is
oops
115 yep be
right not that I was looking over your
you ought to pass as amended okay um you
yep go ahead clear close the
rooll representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes belli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes cabro yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan Jack yes chairman
okay motion carries vote of 18 to zip
all those in favor of placing on the
consent Calendar please say I I those
opposed so move
damous okay House Bill 1257 relative to
contracts between Public Adjusters and
the
insured uh represent prelli I have you
made the
motion it's okay I can make the motion
if you don't want
no I was not on this one what's that I
don't believe I was okay you were not
okay all right so uh representative hunt
the sponsor of the bill seconded by
representative
legislate is there any discussion on the
itl okay seeing none the C will call the
role
all right representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes M yes pachelli yes
zton Walsh Burrows yes Herbert yes clerk
yes M yes collabro yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan Jack yes chairman hunt yes
18 Z vote carries the 18 event all those
in favor placing on the consent Calendar
please say I I those
oppos no
moved okay 1259 relative Property and
Casualty Insurance laws administered by
the insurance
department so I I will move and second
and representative Bros will second the
amendment
0762 and this this is a technical
Corrections Bill housekeeping Bill and
this this amendment just to clarify I
misprint okay everybody okay with the
motion of
to pass with
Amendment okay the clerk will call the
amendment
125 all right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole yes MCU yes pelli
yes taxton yes Walsh yes burrow yes
Herbert yes Clark yes m yes cabro yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes Jack yes chairman
hunt
yes on the amendment okay the motion now
is ought to pass as
on all right okay representative Ammon
yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes
belli yes Faxton Walsh yes Heros yes
Herbert yes bur yes Mair yes cabro yes
Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes chairman hunt
yes all right 18 Z 18 to zip um all
those in favor replacing uh 1259 on the
consent Calendar please say
I those
opposed moved unanimously and we're now
on to
liquor
okay first up House Bill 1135 relative
to the definition of specialty
beers I have representative salivan
itl
okay any discussion on the motion of
RO representative Ammon yes pusk yes
poost yes Cole yes yes pelli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
yes M yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear
yes Sullivan Jack yes jamman hunt yes 18
Z motion carries 18 to zip all those in
favor of placing on the consent Calendar
please say I those
opposed moved
unanimously okay House Bill 1321
relative to repealing the penalties for
the sale of keg of Malt Beverages
this 2 one two three okay it was the
amount of
fluids 64 ounces I
think okay all
right and I have representative Sullivan
made the
motion you ready is there was
it okay the motion is going to be ought
to pass on the amendment
okay and it was Sullivan
hunt this is 13 House Bill 1321 this is
okay any discussion on the
motion see none the clerk will call the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes o
yes Cole yes the yes pelli yes taxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes mclair yes Calabro yes spear
yes skip somebody Gibbs
yes Sullivan Jack yes and chairman hunt
yes this is ought to pass on the
amendment 180 18 to zip okay now the
motion is ought to pass as
amended uh representative Sullivan
second by representative hunt any
motion
oh
pass
right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Cole
yes yes belli yes Daxton yes Walsh yes
burrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes Maier yes Calabro yes
Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan yes Jack yes chamman
hunt
yes 18 to zero okay uh vot carries 18 to
zip all those in favor placing 1321 on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those
opposed so moved
unanimously okay 1334 relative to the
sale of beer and a refillable containers
representative
pusc seconded by representative Sullivan
pass any discussion on the motion of
Growlers
roll all right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes post yes Co
yes yes belli yes taxton yes Walsh yes
Burrows yes Herbert yes L yes
yes collabro yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes chairman hunt
yes 18 to
zero pass okay um all those in favor of
placing on the consent Calendar please
say I I those opposed so move D
nously okay House Bill 1702 relative to
oversight Liquor Commission funding and
repealing the Liquor
Commission uh we have represented pusk
uh second M by representative hunt moves
interim
study okay uh was it Hunton pusk uh pusk
and
I guess we I'm sorry hold
on yeah that one we act did we didn't we
that should not have been on there that
bill we've already done it we've already
done it that was that was an early Bill
okay okay all right is the motion clear
we're talking about House Bill 1702
the motion is interim
study any discussion on the
motion all right seeing none the clerk
will call the role representative Ammon
yes pusk uh yes poost yes Cole yes M yes
pelli yes Daxton Walsh yes buros yes
Herbert yes CL yes M yes collabro yes
Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack
Z okay all in favor placing on the
consent Calendar please say I those
opposed so mooved in the
Amis okay uh 1018 is another one of
those that still needs to be
okay
[Music]
1076 relative to Wine manufacturer
Alliance
alliances so
what 1076 do we have the right Amendment
for
1076 right here I know I'm just checking
commission what we have the number we
have here there it's two different
940 okay not 940 950 is the correct
one somewhere not
ours somebody else got that lucky
number play that on your mega Buck today
okay so now it's going to be the
amendment number 2024 d
950 H
okay mve by uh I I have my name so it's
buam
okay anybody want to discuss the
amendment see see
representative Ammon yes on the
amendment
M pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes
pachelli yes jaon Walsh yes burrow yes
Herbert yes Clark yes mle yes Calabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes
Su Sullivan yes Jack yes chairman hunt
yes 18 Z on now the motion is ought to
pass as amended is there any discussion
on the motion of ought to pass with aund
buo see none the clerk will call the
role
representative Ammon yes pusk yes poost
yes
Cole yes mchu yes pelli yes Daxton Walsh
yes Burrows yes Herbert yes clerk yes
maer yes collabro yes
Gibbs
spear yes Sullivan Jack yes chairman
hunt
yes
pass okay all those in favor placing on
776 on the consent Calendar please say I
I those opposed so move
damous okay next up House Bill 1151
relative to carrying alcohol beverages
on Hotel premises i' like to make a
motion
okay representative Cole second B by
represent buo moves out to pass on the
amendment
0768 it's also in our packet you got
24 and didn't we also move the artist
perform the 1582 up to that inside that
bill that Amendment is that the one we
we combine two bills into one Amendment
yeah since were both referring to the
same section of the
law
okay so the motion is on the on the
eight
768 okay clerk will call the role when
she's
amendment pusk uh yes post yes Cole yes
mugh yes pachelli yes taxton Walsh yes
burrow yes Herbert yes cler yes mclair
yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes
yes
oops okay now the motion is ought to
pass as
amended Z
yet
right okay the motion is ought to pass
on the amend as amended the court will
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes M yes pachelli yes
taxton Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk yes M yes cabro
yes Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan Jack
yes okay all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so move
damous chair I have a question yes um
you made a mention to
1582 is that now rolled into the that
that the the intent of that bill is
rolled into uh what we just passed yes
exactly so that that bill when we get to
it we'll just inter room study it okay
thank
you okay so next up is
Sullivan uh second seconded
by who do we who who second it do we
have any notes who second it okay
okay okay representative Souther second
by Cole U moves uh ought to pass on
House Bill
1227 there's no
we want to give all the F to the sener
sen and see what they do with
right all right it's to pass 1227
correct representative Ammon yes pusk
yes post yes Cole yes MCU yes melli yes
Axton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes her
yes clerk yes mclair yes Calabro yes
Gibbs yes spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes jamman hunt
yes all those in favor and placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
unanimously okay 1358 we're still
waiting for that
Amendment did you say itl on that a to
pass on the last one on the last one to
pass on the last one okay this one here
is is the contract manufacturing beer
wine uh we still we haven't gotten our
Amendment for that yet so stay tuned on
that
one
okay um next one is 1374 relative to
liquor licenses for uh
restaurants and I have representative
Sullivan second represent hunt to
one wait a
minute
1374 um yeah I know I'm again I could
have been wrong last night I know but I
that yeah what was this one what does
when you the
mic this is changing from 15 50% to 15%
oh yeah that we we just moved it in
started right yeah I was being nice to
you I was being nice by not putting up a
fight after the the extended hours
compromise right and it was fun for the
rest of us to
watch so yes I do want to kill it but
I'm okay with interim
study okay
all right uh all right so is the
question clear the motion is interim
study on 1374 and the clerk will call
the
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole
yes
yes pelli yes baxton Walsh yes burrow
yes Herbert yes cler yes M yes cabro yes
Gibbs yes spear yes Sullivan yes Jack
yes okay the motion carries to 18 to
zip um all those in favor consent
Calendar please say I I those
opposed
okay next up house bill on consent yeah
oh didn't I just take that vote all
those in favor and say consent say
yes I don't have the right sheet here
that's I know that's all
right play the tape back okay I'll spell
1380 relative to brew pub
licenses so representative hunt second
Ed by represent buo moves ought to pass
on Amendment
and this amendment just lowers the uh
gallonage from 5,000 to 2500 to match up
pups any discussion on the
amendment okay seeing none the clerk
will call the
role representative Ammon yes on the
amendment pusk yes post yes Cole yes M
yes melli yes Daxton Walsh yes burrow
yes Herbert yes clerk yes Mair
yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes
spear yes sorry
tvin Jack yes hunt yes 18 to zero on the
amendment okay motion now from represent
hunt second by repres buo moves off to
pass as amended is there any discussion
motion seeing none the clerk will call
the
role on to pass as amended on 1
representative Ammon yes pusk yes post
yes Cole yes M yes pelli yes Daxton yes
Walsh yes Burrows yes Herbert yes lur
yes mclair yes collabro yes Gibbs yes
spear yes Sullivan y Jack yes chairman
hunt yes to pass as amended on 1380 okay
all those who in favor of placing 1380
on the consent Calendar please say I I
unanimously all right next up uh House
Bill 1540 relative to the definitions of
full course meals and full service
restaurants for the purpose of alcohol
licensing representative suin second by
representative hunt moves ought to pass
an 0939
n any discussion on the motion to ought
amendment seeing none the clerk will
rooll all right representative Ammon yes
pusk yes poost yes Cole yes M yes belli
yes jaon Walsh yes Barrow yes Herbert
yes clerk yes maer yes Calabro yes Gibbs
yes spear yes Sullivan Jack yes chamman
hunt
yes
amended any discussion on the motion who
representative Sullivan second by
representative
role
all right representative Ammon
yes pusk yes post yes Cole yes M yes
belli yes Daxton Walsh yes Burrows yes
Herbert yes clerk yes mclair
yes cabro yes Gibbs spear yes
Sullivan Jack yes chamman hunt yes 18 to
zero okay now the motion is ought to
pass as amended oh that we just did that
did okay all those in favor of the
consent Calendar please say
I those
opposed I get for jumping ahead
okay uh next up is House Bill 1582 which
we're represented pusc and buo we're
going to interim study that as a case
something would happen to 11:51 on the
way to the senate or way to the
governor's desk okay what was that other
words the same material the issue in
1582 is now in
1151 okay so we're just going to interim
study 1582 y so that we can discuss it
if something were to happen on the way
to the on the way to the
study but we're taking this up yeah in
another
bill we've got to make sure that the
starts are you planning to K this no I'm
I know we put it in the hotel we put it
you can walk around with your drinks and
you can and you can this is New
Hampshire you can be a rock and whe star
still
drink I I've heard stories that some
bands would refuse to play in New
Hampshire because we didn't allow there
are legislators who won't go out to
think somebody's got to maintain the
three Martini
lunch okay the motion is uh interim
study the clerk will call the
role
representative Ammon yes pusk yeah post
yes Cole yes M yes pachelli yes Daxton
yes Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
clerk
yes M yes Calabro yes Gibbs yes spear
yes
Sullivan oh he stepped out um Jack yes
and chairman hunt yes so 17 to
zero zip all those in favor placing on
the consent Calendar please say I I
those opposed so move
damous okay House Bill 1624
representative Ammon seconded by
representative bullo moves a two
pass on relative to allowing the
distillation of hobby
liquers
role representative Ammon yes pusk yes
post yes Cole yes migu yes belli yes
taxton yes Walsh yes Burrows yes yes
Herbert yes clar yes mclair yes Calabro
yes Gibbs yes Spar yes
Sullivan Jack yes chairman hunt
yes
18 okay the vote is 18 to zero all those
in favor of placing 1624 on the consent
Calendar please say I I those
opposed so
moved and last but not least
House Bill 1591 relative to fines for
prohibited sales of
tobacco uh representative hunt second by
representative buroughs moves ought to
pass on the amendment number
[Music]
amendment seeing none the clerk will
rooll
last what was 18 yeah yeah it was 1582
cuz right representative Ammon yes on
the amendment on the amendment pusk yes
post yes Cole yes yes pachelli yes
Jaxon Walsh yes burrow yes Herbert yes
cler yes M yes cabro yes Gibbs yes spear
yes
Sullivan Jack yes shamman hunt
yes it's ought to pass on the amendment
18 zero okay now the motion is ought to
pass as amended on House Bill
1591 is any discussion on the
buros clerk will call the role on oop
pass as amended 1591 1591 good
representative Ammon yes
yes post oh pusk yes post yes Cole yes
migu yes belli yes Daxton Walsh yes fos
yes Herbert yes cler yes M yes labro yes
Gibbs yes fear yes Sullivan yes Jack yes
it was yeah 18 zip okay uh 18 zip who
said
no okay all those in favor of placing on
the cons Calendar please say I I those
opposed so moved
unanimously and we are now out of exact
session thank you all very very
much
wow okay didn't
recognize okay
you
e
for
okay yeah who's on yeah which this is
the business committee this business
right
section you have made just the one that
um
so
[Music]
Cole's
andt so we eliminate
Herbert and he's here right then we got
one two three four
five okay
I you have all Ds right because that's
not going to work
I mean I I mean I you have to pick up
pus no two three two six six
okay okay so this is the business
subcommittee and we
have
Ammon Cole hunt and Maier
Gibbs and Spear and spear you're there
three and three you're on the second
line you know that's what happens when
you're s you're down on the second line
is
that but so are we
all some of some okay 1033 relative to
advertising of nominal dimensions of
lumber um Carrie and I fought over this
as to who was going to um make the
motion and who was going to second it
I'd like to make the motion she's going
to Second it but she gets to write up
the uh blur the
blurb do we have a a nfw uh designation
for some people don't get it not for
prime time no um nfw
nfw it's
i you're lucky your mic was on
okay so we kind of made the decisions
amongst ourselves we fought it
out okay just do it and so just make
your motion it better be I make the
motion this okay and I second it
okay your motion was itl
yes do you feel that we need a
discussion
no
okay I think we affected that today this
morning
you make a discussion no no I'm going to
blurb so representative okay the motion
is representative Spears second by
representative mulier
to in exped Alle say all right yeah I'll
just say a couple words like I
appreciate the the representative for
filing this bill um and I understand
like
technically the lumber isn't actually
the measure measurement um but I I don't
see this bill going anywhere so I'm I'm
on board with the motion thank you
us
okay you're you know my mic will pick up
what you say so you got to be careful
okay the motion is inexpedient to
legislate um all those in favor of itl
raise your hand one two three four
five wait who's who's raising a hand
that shouldn't be raising a hand over
there Ammon Cole hunt Mair Gibbs and
okay all right HB 1117 Rel to creating a
committee to study the protection of
business operators against requests to
accommodate customers with fraudulent or
untrained service
animals do we really want to create a
committee
well I mean it's definitely needed this
problem so
room there's probably a few because the
question well my feeling is and actually
you're probably the best person to
answer this repr gives okay my feeling
is that any business should be able to
decide decide whether they're going to
allow a dog or not they should just be
allowed now I understand there is
federal legislation regulated to you
know handicap you know people have so if
we were to say is if that that hotel
owner was um going to Bar a deaf person
to bring a dog
in you know I I'm pretty sure that they
wouldn't okay the issue is that when
people show up with these service
animals if we were to say the New
Hampshire statute is clear you're not
that service animal is not a service dog
it's illegal and if you want to pursue a
case you'll have to pursue it in federal
court unfortunately for that proposal
there is State legislation as well so
that's not going to work so what's in in
the state legisl what's in the state
current state law that's not making not
working
well as you said it's it's something of
an unsolvable problem but you cannot
discriminate against people with
disabilities so if it's a genuine
service dog and it's not allowed and in
fact there's a separate statute that
relates specifically to guide dogs um
which apply to both deaf and blind
people state state law state law okay um
so that's really not not going to work
um do we have a state law that says that
service dogs are not
considered companion dog Comfort dog
Comfort dog Comfort dog okay com com
Comfort dog okay Comfort companion dog
do we have a law saying that a hotel
owner can refuse a companion dog the law
is the book we don't have anything
specifically about that but one could
argue that it companion dog is not a
service dog if it's a service dog it has
to be allowed I understand service dog
okay I mean I understand the DEA and and
I mean I in in my mind it was it was
originally a blind and it was DEA and
there's actually um insulin the dogs who
can smell the diabetes okay th those are
the three also uh epilepsy and epilepsy
okay so in terms of when people if if a
land if a hotel owner says no I'm not
going to rent the room to you to a comp
because because of the companion because
it's a companion dog turn your mic on
please my mic is on so I'm not going to
rent to you because your dog is just a
companion dog but they do that all the
time that's their decision and they and
they' make that decision with a risk
that they could get
sued and they say to the to the to the
the rent the the guest you want to sue
us go ahead but I'm not going to rent
you as the law stands they may be able
to do that I I would not you know put my
hand down and swear to it they may be
able to do that I would not be in favor
of actually putting something in statute
saying that they could do it no to do to
Sue sorry what what to Sue or not to sue
yes yeah come on I wouldn't be in favor
of saying they could refuse no I think
as it stands they probably can refuse if
it's a companion animal rather than a
service animal and the Same by the way
under federal law federal law does not
protect companion animals except in
housing in housing the landlord cannot
refuse a companion animal if the if the
animal um provides um assistance based
on um uh psychiatric need um that is
it's not just a companion animal it's a
comfort an
for psychiatric need but that would not
apply to public accommod PSD dog yeah
yes that would not apply to public
accommodations so I think under for
public accommodations they probably can
refuse an animal that is not a service
animal does that make sense I would not
however be in favor of actually putting
that into statutory language I think
it's okay as it
stands so tell us what you hope this
committee is going to solve so so I
think what this bill did was created a
study committee originally correct and
we had encour we generally don't like I
know you don't as you can see just in
this three minutes this is a very
complicated issue and it really has
become an enormous problem for
businesses but to just back up a second
so technically a business uh can refuse
to have an animal come into the building
where they run the risk is if it is a
legitimate service animal they then face
fines penalties Etc from the Ada right
so person okay so let let just stop
right there so they they risk that's
right they risk that yes okay so uh that
means that the the person the the guest
has to drop a dime to correct to hurt
hurt your old Department would they
would you take those to my old
Department uh or the Federal Department
of Justice which enforces the Ada
correct okay yes right so if the hotel
owners calling that person's
Bluff and said okay fine give them a
call right which happens from time to
time and as as I shared with you the uh
the example when I testified there was
an incident um I think it was last
summer where somebody came to a
restaurant claimed it was a service
animal clearly was not a service animal
it was yippy and jumpy and all that
stuff which you know business owners we
can usually tell pretty much right away
whether or not they're a legitimate
service animal or not that person person
said if you don't let me in I'm calling
the police the business owner said let
me give you my our phone let we'll help
you call the police the police came they
issued the citation um and there is in
New Hampshire statute right now I think
it's a $1,000 $1,200 penalty for
misrepresenting a service animal except
that there's no teeth to it because it's
un enforceable nobody will enforce it
it's a civil matter so this is where we
go down to this whole Rabbit Hole of
well how do we give it some teeth to
where when it there legitimately is not
a service animal that the business owner
has some recourse or there is some
penalty that would be paid by the uh
misrepresenting
party so you want okay so when that law
enforcement officer showed up you said
he wrote or she wrote a citation I think
technically they just filled out a
report I don't think they made any
determination report now what what
becomes so at that moment could the uh
restaurer say to the law enforcement I
um I think they have violated the stat
that they're trying to force this dog on
me when I you don't have to which this
business did this business also had
signs posted in the window we do not
allow anything but service animals right
um but then was followed up with
subsequently with um you know uh demand
letters from this person's attorney
saying if you don't send us $30,000
within the next 90 days we're going to
take you to court we're going to do this
we're going to do so now he has to
engage an attorney so now he has all
these additional expenses and at the end
of the day the Battle of attorneys yeah
those people because that we all knew
from the start this was not a legitimate
service animal of course that whole
claim went radio silent but that doesn't
absolve the poor business owner from
having to go through that entire process
no he didn't have to he could have
dropped the case just as much as the
other person dropped the case right sure
but usually you don't know who that
individual is right you just have an
well I guess I I was just looking at the
real
world saying is that that if someone
showed up and and I Can See Clearly this
is this is you know not a service dog
and say no I refuse to serve you and the
person say I want to call the police and
say well fine but at this point would
you please exit my establishment and go
call the police do whatever you want to
do and we'll take it from there and then
that person would you know obviously
walk down the street not byother the
call police but if they actually did and
the police showed up then the uh the
restaurant owner could
say you know uh I
could look at the other the know
assuming that other person is still
sitting there and say I will uh if they
don't make you know drop this accusation
I will pursue this other counter case
which is that you're violating and then
I would think at that point in time the
person say okay let's Let It Go Walk
Away I I I guess I'm just wondering is
because this is so un enforcable because
we have no vehicle to solve this in
terms of law enforcement
probably doesn't want to get involved in
it in either way nobody wants any part
of this to be perfectly honest with you
and that's the challenge and so
therefore I mean we can create a study
committee but I just don't know what's
going to come out of the study committee
and I think where the rub for the
business owner is so if they do all of
the things you just suggest right which
I think would be the logical progression
you would follow right at the end of
that discussion we still don't
necessarily have a name address or any
identifying factors of this individual
that we could then uh pursue a case with
anyway right Mr chairman order do you
want to pursue the case Mr chairman yes
representative Gibbs thank you um okay
in the first place there's nothing the
police could do on either side of a
claim like that the police have no
enforcement Authority criminal correct
so calling the police would not do
either side any good um in the second
place the claim for $30,000 was
obviously not going to go anywhere and
as you say it it did not uh so I think
we could write all kinds of new
legislation and it would still come down
to is this a service animal or not and
unless you're
actually um you know on site or um the
um uh person with the dog had some kind
of paperwork which mostly doesn't exist
um it would be very difficult to decide
now the person denied could bring a
claim to the Human Rights Commission or
to um the uh federal department of
justice under the Ada but if it's not a
service animal that claim will not go
anywhere the thing of it is there is no
such thing and I I am a lawyer as it
happens um although I'm only uh licensed
to practice in Massachusetts um uh
there's no such thing as a self-
enforcing law you can't enforce it by
saying Oh no you're you're wrong you
know pay the fine you pretty much always
have to go to some agency or to court so
if the person is
lying um and there's a statute which
says it's illegal to falsely claim that
that an animal the service animal then
you can take that person to court under
that statute if the P if the if the
um uh animal is a service animal then
the person who brought the animal can go
either as I said to the Department of
Justice or uh to the Human Rights
Commission or both uh but that's how it
would have to work and I don't think
there's any additional legislation which
is going to help it represent m l ju
just a quick question if if a service
dog is trained don't they get some sort
of a a designation a certificate they
don't they do not and there is no
licensing Authority there is no like
official papers that you have to be
issued there is nothing
that would solve the problem it would
but it would be a federal issue but
there would have to be an agency that
was authorized to issue the paperwork
either on a state or federal level and
authorized right so ultimately where the
business owner ends up falling is if you
have a legitimate service animal and you
are denied service right there is a
recourse for that individual but as the
business owner there is no
recourse well if if
I can't say much for the restaurant but
most restaurants they usually have your
name and your phone
number you know when you make a res
small percentage of restaurants take
reservations most of them it's first
come first serve so you but a hotel
would know a hotel would know
potentially yes okay so but I I guess
what do you think could come out of the
study committee I was leaving it to the
really smart people in the room to come
back and tell me what could come out of
it we just had a good and then and all
we could all I would say you know I mean
best I can give you interim study and we
can talk about this again some more but
at this point I I have no brilliant idea
other than I would just say you just
stare someone down and say okay you
really want to go to court over this and
really we were just trying to impress on
the committee just how much of a problem
this has really become for businesses
and I would say I am very impressed that
problem thank you I just listening to
your explanation of that scenario I'll
I'll add that I understand that it's a
problem as well uh but
unfortunately I don't have the solution
to that problem I wish I did because
it's a problem for people who have
disabilities and who have genuine
service animals because it puts them in
a situation of having to argue that it's
really a service animal because other
people have falsely claimed it correct
okay and so uh speak loud and clear I
wanted to throw out an idea and I know
this might be for later um but in the
case where the person with the pet was
going to
and maybe it is fraudulent could
attorney's fees be granted to uh The
Establishment if they lose that that
would be the idea I'm throwing out there
yeah great idea the Florida love yeah I
again I think at this point I think um I
did the research and sent that
collection of information to you folks
so I don't know if there's any great
ideas workable ideas but obviously
something like that that gives some
teeth to it but ultimately it goes back
to
is it enforcable to representative
Hunt's Point and I'm you know this is
where we struggle honestly okay do you
have a copy in the bill what so who's on
your study
committee no idea yeah do you want to
pull it up what do you mean idea you
created this wasn't our bill this is
brought forward independent of us we're
just here and support of it who who
sponsored the bill it one second pull it
me
string that's right yes it's Ren Str no
he's not
committees see I want to see who who
they appoint is it a legislative study
committee or does it get everybody in
his
brother
okay three members of the House three
members of the Senate good luck for that
showing
up so should be attorney there do you
really want to to study kidding me or
you want to have hope that this Commerce
Committee can work this come up with a
solution come September I leave it in
sir okay that means you're TR you trust
that this committee can will come up
with some way to to make the legal
oblig if we could pass that it would
need to go to Judiciary if we did that
we I the business Community particularly
in the hospitality sector would be
appreciative of any support or help we
can get right so you would so that the
restaurant would be able to to stare the
person in the eye and say by the way if
I have to pursue this case against you
uh and I win I get the Le we're we're
going to get the legal fees are you
really want to pursue this right so um I
will say that um uh Department of Health
uh food safety actually worked and
generated a whole bunch of posters with
language that was developed I think by
the Department of Justice around this
whole issue right uh We've helped
disseminate them I know they've
disseminated them to a bunch of lenses
Etc so again they're I think agencies
are getting pressure from industry to
help them do something um so just
recognizing that and and how we move
forward I I I don't necessar have a
clear answer okay what's it going to be
successful so the department you guys
want to weigh in and say anything about
this
you good afternoon my name is Colleen
Smith I'm the administrator for the food
protection section within the Department
of Health and Human Services and just to
Echo what Mr Summers said is this is a
has been a long
um ongoing issue with at restaurants
grocery stores in particular we receive
hundreds of consumer complaints each
year that we have to follow up or
patrons see um what's a non-service dog
in a food establishment is against our
rules um however it's very difficult to
enforce we go to follow up on the
complaint the the the service an or the
dog isn't there anymore um we can speak
to the managers but it doesn't mean that
next time someone enters either a
grocery store or a restaurant that that
the the situation isn't going to be the
same you know it's definitely a lot of
pressure especially at a um the entrance
of a store for someone to confront a
patron they don't want to lose business
it um so it's easier just to to you know
look away and and um instead of denying
that person access when it's not a true
service animal and certainly they do
post signs we've um participated in
disseminating signs that are available
through the Secretary of State's website
but um you know people can ignore those
signs and and unfortunately it it's it
seems like it's um only becoming more
and more common for this to
happen okay
any thank you all right um so I I think
we should interim study this bill and
and we'll take it up in September when
we can hopefully have figured out a
brilliant solution for this problem Mr
speaker
speaker Mr
chairman I'm sorry the promotion uh I
have a minor problem with line
18 right well we're talking about
interim studying the bill and it says
Library it will be due to the State
library oner before November 1st
2024 that will give whoever three months
okay to get this done and I don't
believe doing Justice in three months
okay are we all right with inter room
study yeah okay representa Cole you want
to make that motion are you on this
who's on this yes I'm on this committee
I'll make the motion to interim
study represent hunt moves to interim
study any discussion on the motion all
those in favor of in study raise your
hand six
okay all
right onward and upward all right 1395
lives a home heating oil and propane
bills one right this one was the pr
repricing
okayer yes just one and that
no they're for sale did did did they
ever sell the
business but is it is it selling
hopefully coming to
happen I mean you think one of the good
players is going to buy them out for us
us so should we just inter room study
and to stay keep an eye on what's
this okay yeah R speing to the
not according to the notes that I have
it was uh a real issue came up around
the uh the tank being underground being
able to get that tank out of there so
it's not workable the way it is anyway
so if we're going to do anything we got
to fix
that right well in that in having a
berry underground Berry tank is actually
fairly unusual um and and I'm because
and I say that because I'm one of those
people who who has several and uh and
because most people just have above
ground tanks unless you're trying to
heat your house with propane and then
you've kind of serious and and
theoretically you're you really have
when you do that you're you're selling
your soul to that propane you you've got
to have hopefully done you know know
know what you're getting into with that
propane
dealer so
okay interim study people comfortable
did second I'm sorry yes I will okay all
study
did
okay uh
1430 electorates approved by the public
aties commission for residential
condominium property so n and I had a
nice conversation with the house clerk
about bills going to the right committee
and this
clearly this we're not this is somewhat
inappropriate to come to this committee
but that we have become uh by default
the condo committee uh and I've uh
reminded the house Kirk that we that
happened because of we used to have a
bills seemingly every year that they
were looking for a super lean and uh
which is a financial impact of that of
condo owners are not paying their their
condo fees and the condo association
wants to place a lean um we did resolve
that issue and then now they do have
leans but it's only up to six months of
of back payments um but having said that
this particular issue uh really should
have gone to the energy yeah science and
technology and the issue is that if you
have common
space if then that is a commercial rate
so representative spear I'm making a
face could tell we received a uh an
amendment that was pretty nice and
addressed a lot of what we were
concerned about that maybe we could look
at
it well I guess I I did not read the
amendment too clearly well one of when
we discussed it it there was a problem
with swimming pools uh some in this
particular case it was the so what they
did was they took all that out okay and
the amendment is for septic tanks sewage
uh water supply things that you cannot
live in a house
without yeah but that's not the problem
but that's if they take all that out
then maybe we could look at it so what
what so they're saying there is
something that they should be able to
get at a consumer rate yeah what was
left uh like I said the things that make
it a house they make it a home uh sewage
and and water supply that kind of thing
right CU that's what the bill was all
about was the water it was also for
common area swimming pools and stuff
like that it was more wide reaching but
in particular the problem that he was
focused in on is he here is that Mr
Swift here oh sponsor okay but that the
the the issue that they he was focused
in on was their water
supply okay so I absolutely know in my
town there are houses that have a shared
water
supply and they absolutely pay the
commercial
rate for that so this bill would not
just stop at
condos if it would be part of reaching
of all across the state of any Community
or anybody neighborhood that had a
community
well and that's that is opening a huge
worms am
I
correct my yeah no you just need to talk
to the mic because sorry Manos I'm the
sponsor of the bill um I did um
obviously I can't draft an amendment
because I'm not a member of the
committee but I did send around
yesterday a suggestion that it' be
narrowed strictly to well pumps and um
uh water um which I think I was here at
the hearing uh before the committee when
I introduced the bill and I think that
that addresses a lot of what I at least
heard as the committee's concerns and I
was not understanding your comment chair
WP about so it's not the committee
because the committee has we're we have
no clue about this issue okay what we
what we were explained by the
department okay and they are saying is
that
anybody who has a community water
service so let's take not condos let's
just take home
residential if there's six homes
and they all share one
well that well is build at the
commercial
rate may I respond yes um the bill is
limited to
condos however I I heard the concern
that perhaps it's in the wrong committee
and I would be happy to have it referred
to science energy and technology and if
that's the committee's will I'm
perfectly satisfied with that okay
unfortunately you were to way beyond
that point so you'll just have to
reintroduce this bill next year and make
sure that you phrase it to make it look
like it should go to them and I would
say to you what you want to do is don't
limit the
condos you want to broaden it to anybody
who has Community
water be happy to do that okay thank you
depart and the department is
here there you are in the back did I say
everything
in this is roberes right you know why I
remember your name of course I think
so thank you members of the committee uh
Griffin robers uh State energy program
manager at the department of energy um
again the department does note its uh
opposition to this bill it does it as
introduced um would present several
likely unintended
consequences um as we discussed during
the public hearing um you are giving a
certain subset of commercial entities
the ability to choose what rate
classification they fall under that does
not exist for any other entity in the
state utilities make that determination
based under their rate tariffs approved
by the Public Utilities Commission um
you know in this specific instance we
have a specific Condo Association that
is registered as a COR corporation on
the Secretary of State's website that
runs several pumps that it owns and
those are charged at a commercial rate
because they are in fact a business or
commercial Enterprise now I understand
the argument that they serve um private
residences and that type of thing um
unfortunately the way that the condo
association has its billing and they can
certainly take it up with utility to
change maybe the um the account under
the name of the residents but that cont
Association owns those pumps and when
the condo association is clearly a
business Enterprise register with the
secretary of state it is rightly charged
commercial
rats thank you very much thank
you
motion
Spar okay yeah ITA so okay all right all
those in favor read speaking to
legislate raise your hand one two three
four six
okay all right next up uh 1491
prohibiting the repricing of heating
sale no this can't be no this is this is
this is all the the propane guy just
simply says if he if you as a customer
called up and said
look I want I want to have you
deliver and the prob banking company
says fine you know we'll deliver and he
says I want to pay by credit card and
they going to charge the credit card
now if the propane company if you ask
the prop or in this particular case the
propane only delete delivered on
Thursdays right okay okay and he says
okay well we're going to deliver it but
I can't guarantee you a
price then then then all work if we pass
this bill that basically we're telling
the propane dealer don't take the order
say call me back on Thursday yeah I
thought it was if I order 100 gallons
and I give my credit card over the phone
it's that day that the price you get and
you would deliver that day yeah after he
kept saying he wanted delivery at a
different day you can't do
that you know what I'm
saying it's you got to you you know if
you you want a price you want a credit
card order this is 100 gallons and and
you deliver it as as soon as possible
nobody's nobody I mean I aren't too many
people say I want to deliver a week or
two weeks or now but in this particular
case the awkwardness of the situation
was this propane dealer only delivered
to his town once a week so he's at the
mercy of whatever that price will be on
Thursday yeah and that means that means
I would say to them I said don't charge
my credit card until Thursday
correct you know you have that priority
but then he can refuse
deliver well he wouldn't refuse to deliv
he's going to say I I understand I'm
going to wait till Thursday and I'm I'm
going to be I just this vision of
someone you know seeing a price cuz I
know on my way to the state house
there's one guy has prices up on the
yeah and he say well great I want to get
that gas but I don't need it yet I need
it a week from now because I'm burning
my gas I won't be able to take it and
and you know no that price is not good a
week from now the price is only good
today
so
right
um itl itl is anybody in the room have a
problem with the
itl
no
okay
okay um all those in favor reading speed
to
legislate two three four five six
okay I
second okay all right now we have this
the right to repair stuff 1071 rela to
technology I'm trying to remember what
what was different about this one
uh okay
representar this was
this was kind of limited before they
were do the original bill that we had
dealt with things like uh washing
machines and dryers and everything else
that's what we had this limited limit is
limited to things like computers and
things like that
uh I still I know that the industry is
moving in the direction of allowing
things to be repaired are they you know
even apple is they they'll Supply
certain Apple's still a sealed box you
can't repair anything inside
lot of these compies are fighting no no
apple actually is doing some stuff where
they're doing because there are some
laws especially in Europe but the point
of it is European governments forcing
them to yeah and whatever and and it and
because these companies are uh worldwide
actually right right uh we're not the
only people involved in
it I I I still feel that this is a
market driven opportunity for companies
and not something we should be legisla
down at the state level I
so that's what I
think okay anybody else anybody
want okay represent spear second by
itl all those in favor raise your
hand I assume you're going to raise your
hand yeah
right right six it okay
okay uh 12:43 revising the laws relative
to the retail installment sales of a
motor
vehicle what's this one
about I have no clue then we have a
motor vehicle sticker price that when
wanted to say that it's got part uh no
12275 team proprietary information okay
so what's 1243 you did it
this is your bill oh it's my bill is
this a banking
bill okay thank
you you want to come over and tell us
bill I will I will tell you when I
retire I'll have sponsored more bills
that beame law I have no idea what I did
okay okay
so good afternoon members of the
subcommittee my name is Seth Zaraki I'm
the general counsel at the New Hampshire
banking Department um this is a bill
revising the law on the retail
installment sales of Motor Vehicles um
which is admin this law is administered
by the banking Department it will
substantially revise um RSA 361a in its
entirety really the the main idea of
this bill is to U modernize that statute
to bring it in line with our other
statutes it's a rewrite of the whole
section um and we worked um in
collaboration with um industry experts
including the uh New Hampshire Auto
Dealers Association in drafting this
bill
um so um happy to answer any questions
said what does the bill actually do yeah
so I I think in general I would
characterize it in uh really three ways
um so 36 RSA 361a was first enacted over
60 years ago um and there have been peac
meal amendments to that statute over
time and we believe the statute would
benefit from a broader reorganization at
this time um these amendments will
restructure RSA 361a so that it aligns
with the other state laws that we
administer um that govern the licensing
of consumer credit entities um that's
the first one number two the banking
department has observed a moderate
increase in the number of consumer
complaints relating to car dealerships
in New Hampshire um including those that
are engaged in the business of uh retail
Sellers and sales finance companies
there was a um pretty big enforcement
action brought by the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office in that
concluded in December
2022 um and this bill is designed to
strengthen um some protections for
consumers who enter into retail
installment contracts when purchasing
Motor Vehicles in New Hampshire um and
that will be done through among other
things regular exams and and enhanced um
credential standards for retail sellers
so um going forward this would result in
examinations of um retail sellers on a
regular um exam cycle by the New
Hampshire banking Department um and um
and like I said before we we worked on
this um rewrite in collaboration with
the New Hampshire Auto Dealers
Association in doing that sounds like an
mulier thank you very much thank you
Sor yes sorry um so I had in my notes
that um they would be submitting an
addition to the bill for an amendment do
we have that
Amendment yes we submitted that um
before the public hearing um the first
one back roughly two months ago and my
understanding was that was with the um
that went to the office of legislative
services I don't see it on the website
but
um we did submit
right
okay
all right so what's in this amendment
looks like it rewrite the whole thing no
I guess not section one of the bill by
replacing no I'd be H I can I can speak
to that okay okay yeah it does really
four things and again we worked on this
um amendment in collaboration with with
the Auto Dealers Association um the
first thing it revises the effective
date the original Bill had an effective
date of July 1 of this year um this will
push it to Jan one of
2025 um we believe um both the
department and business would benefit
from that six additional months to
prepare um for the new law um it
modifies the definition of significant
event in the statute um under under the
um under the bill lenses must report
report what's called significant event
so if there's a significant regulatory
action against that lcy by another state
for example um they would have to report
it to the banking department and this um
this revises the definition of
significant event in the statute and we
really wanted to strike the right
balance between requiring lenses to
report um significant events but not
being o overly burdensome on what they
need to report
um it modifies the section of Bill that
pertains to the initial license term for
Li lies and really this deals with the
situation where a new license is
approved toward the end of the year in
November or December um this would not
require a ly that's approved in that
two-month period to renew the license
almost immediately at the end of the
year P licenses that uh we administer
expire at the end of the year so this
would give those new licenses an extra
up to two months and then uh at the
beginning of when they're first uh
approved by the department and then
the last thing is there are some
technical and clarifying changes to the
examination Authority Section again this
this this section in particular we
worked very closely with the Auto
Dealers Association and it was really
just to um provide clarifying uh
revisions to that section so that
there's a clear understanding of what's
process the amendment okay OTP OTP on
the amendment yeah
GPA okay all those in favor say I I 1
two three four five six okay not to pass
has
maer by me it's
fine okay uh everybody in favor R to
amended one two three
four represent M you're raising your
hand right
okay okay thank you very
much okay uh all right now relative
requiring notice to Consumers of
vehicles that require repair solely
through a dealership and contain
proprietary
information uh I mean if anybody doesn't
know that the computer computer's in the
in the car the new
car is not paying attention is that a
buyer beware issue I don't
know
spear the only place I'm having problem
with this with this uh with the
interpretation I don't expect that
anyone should be able to fix the
computer itself right but I do expect
that they should be able
to buy the
computer bu the but actually no I don't
you know something don't want to do that
because there's a lot of setup that's
involved when I read my users manual
there's a lot of setup involved and
that's not front of the amateure you
need a lot of equipment to do that yeah
this I mean yes the nature of cars today
is that they're incredibly proprietary
and yes they want you to take it back to
the service center and my assumption is
the reason the reason why the the
manufacturers uh you know the how much
money the dealer makes on selling the
car is very little and over the years
it's shrunk and trunk and trunk and is
because they the manufacturers is
telling the dealers you'll make it up in
surface but there's another real reason
there's another real reason if those
cars if those computers are not set up
right with the right mixture of air and
the right mixture of gasoline and
everything else that it does you could
end up in a liability situation where
somebody dies and so I think that
just you know I and I've worked a lot on
Military uh or automob Auto uh
Automobiles and those things are very
tricky to set up so I I don't think that
it's just something for an amateur to
do but this okay yes this bill want if
you recall wanted a label just sign yeah
but the label could be this long of what
is not right um shall I fix a label to
the rear window of the vehicle um that
will require any repairs that can be
only made at a dealership so the list
can be quite long and then we talked
about what about you know motorcycles
and other other vehicles so this was
just that label the bill the way I
understood it a sign it's just a sign on
the door no no on the on the car right
right
represent I was having a hard time
during the public hearing wrapping my
head around like what constitutes a
proprietary part right like is it a a
single nut somewhere that's you need a
special wrench for right like how how do
you determine the thousands of parts
that are on a vehicle right so
unworkable to
BR now we know where all the cups are
going um yeah I mean if there is going
to be a notice on the car and it talks
about proprietary information they might
also want to notti note that when you
have these computers they get
proprietary information from you about
you and about the car personal
information they do cuz I heard it on
NPR today they know more about they know
more about you than you know about
yourself no they said for you know it is
it is an issue for some people don't
want that isn't didn't I see Progressive
some of these insurance companies they
they they'll know how fast you're going
they'll know whether you're a speeder or
yeah
tell turn that GPS off on your
phone you're telling you're telling
Google everything you you know where you
shop what time you
shop what are you shopping for you know
that they do that now you see it on your
computer all the time I I I appreciate
having them give me my uh every month
they tell me where everywhere I've been
and where I and when I was there and
would you like a buy a second thing of
whatever that was you just bought that's
that's the company I'm just talking
about the Google
Maps tracking me so okay uh so uh itl
yeah
hunt all right all that's in favor raise
your hand one two three four five six
those
opposed are you for okay okay you didn't
okay it didn't get my head swivel around
fast
enough okay next on okay rela to
requirements for sewage Disposal Systems
information be disclosed during a real
estate
transaction so this one was agreed upon
bill right the department wants us to
pass this right okay there's any
Amendment for this are we good with the
is
pass uh we're done with this one already
we're going to pass this one
I okay this was dealing with an obscure
remember I made the motion spear second
attention Okay the one we've all been
waiting for House Bill 1320 relative to
real property in flood risk
disclosure so I I'm not excited about
this bill at all um when I found out
that everybody's house flooded this
weekend everybody's house flooded now do
I have to report
that did you did you did you read the
amendment uh I don't know I have it's
amendment number
1122 okay what does the amendment say
the amendment said is limited to
National flood incidences and not to any
man-made uh requirement you know not to
any man-made flooding like some tenants
do some really bad things to houses oh
yeah that's eliminated and it's has to
situation so was Hampton
a national flood situation is Hampton
flood sure yes go over get yeah I would
say so yeah I don't know was it no it
doesn't happen for you don't let me read
the exact the feds don't make a ruling
for like a month or two months away let
me let me get you the exact words the
bill only the the bill only refers to
situ notification when there's a
transaction when there's either a sale
or someone is um leasing the property so
there's no there's no notice requirement
after this weekend's flooding for
anybody nobody has to provide any notice
of that unless they are going to sell
their home in the future or rent it or
rent
it so it's only uh it's only going to
the Future and you think that's okay so
that means sometime when I want to
sell that summer home I have in
handed that I have to tell them if I
know there was a federal flood in in my
in in in around my house there's two
there's two requirements there's you you
need to let a prospective
purchaser or renter know whether the
home is in a flood
zone or whether whether there was any
flood damage that occurred from natural
sources and that's the and that's the
and that's the change we made from
natural sources during the time that you
own the property what we were trying to
do in representative speak here you know
raise this issue is trying to
distinguish between a flood that occurs
because the sum pump broke or somebody
poured sand down the toilet that clogged
up the uh septic system that's not
something that we're trying to address
we're trying to just address situations
that are caused by natural events such
as flooding from Tides river river
flooding Etc so this has actually
happened there are some people who
bought a house that was naturally
flooded the flood the flood was reported
in the newspaper and everybody knew
there was a flood and
and you're requiring the person who
sells the house to disclose it and if
happens what happens to that person who
said t i that was 10 years ago and I
forgot all about
it the same thing that happens if they
they we would be adding this to the
sales the purchase and sales agreement
so the same thing would happen if they
fail to disclose information on on a on
a purchase and sale agreement which is
I'm not I I don't know okay well someone
who's been around for those those all
those statutes but it's very what we've
done is we've added it to the purchase
and sale
agreement similarly to the requirement
to disclose lead arsonic and
radon correct and that is based on the
person who actually had done those
tests okay how would I know I this is a
summer home I don't know what happens to
my summer home when I'm not
there well if it got flooded you would
no what I'm saying is the flooding is so
minor and this bill says you got I need
to report it because there was a federal
notice everybody knew about it excuse me
everybody seemingly knew about it except
the person who's buying it seems to be
ignorant that there're that that they're
they live in a place like this well you
you I want to back up for a second you
asked me has this actually happened and
the and what I what I shared with you is
some um input I received from a
constituent of mine who lives in an area
that floods routinely and in his um in
the note he talks about there were at
least four people in his neighborhood
who bought homes in 16 18 1920 and 21
who were never informed that there was
any that that there that they were in a
flood zone or they had had any flooding
until they went to the to get a mortgage
and at that point for a lot of
purchasers it it's too late because when
they find out that all of a sudden
they're in a flood zone and they have to
purchase flood insurance and now all of
a sudden they've got a they've got a
budget for an additional five $110,000
extra in flood insurance so that that
screws up the whole economics of their
home purchase so what we're trying to do
these people paid cash for their
house then went to the bank to get a
mortgage and the bank said oh by the way
did you know you're in a flood plane if
they paid cash and never got a mortgage
they'd never know about it
exactly so what we're trying to do is
we're trying to help out those people
who bought a house who made that
decision because anybody who did Finance
because I I most the mor most of the
sales I see it's always pending
financing okay okay so you're now just
saying oo well so now we're going to put
a statute in there for those people who
don't have that due diligence that the
even the bank could do that they
couldn't do before they bought it and
we're going to put in this statute about
by the way Hampton
floods I think it had to do with
Realtors as well right on real rather
than as much as I'd like to think I'm an
expert on this I'm
not um I did actually have a there are
are a couple people that have joined me
today that are much better at this uh
than I am and have much more experience
with them if I could have them come up
that would be we in the meantime
representative pelli has has a comment
I'm I'm very sensitive to this because I
also represent the Sea Coast okay so the
and thank you for bringing this forward
right we we have obviously we have
issues with but it's not only flooding
it's also drainage issues so I spoke to
five different Realtors on the Sea Coast
because I wanted to get their
perspective what do they tell what do
they know how are they informing their
perspective buyers and every one of them
without you know I didn't give them that
much information every one of them
referred to me to the um property
disclosure forms that they must fill out
and it's very clearly stated in
disclosure yes the current disclosure
forms what's not what's on the gray area
is drainage which which is probably if
you're trying to inform o uh potential
buyers that there may be water issues
flooding is not the only issue that
would cause problems with their home and
water issues so I do not live in a
federally designated you know a flood
zone but every house on my street has a
su pump because we have drainage issues
and I think that's also something if
you're trying to cover the perspective
buyer that needs to be addressed but I'm
not sure what it is that we're trying to
add to the or what process we're trying
to
improve I may your expert you're got
your experts
doing ad on this I'll let them introduce
themselves okay and but and I will
distribute the amendment that that's
great representative Grassi and I
drafted okay U rep chairman hun yes
represent we were given a example right
from the real there's nothing in there
about
floods and they said their attitude is
buy or beware the realtor theor the
realtor okay so can you answer this
question is this or not in the standard
realtor form that I know that I've seen
because I I've wrote half the statutes
in it the these disclosure things and uh
so what is in there do what page is that
on that that disclosure piece can you
number yeah so what what property
disclosure form property disclosure it's
under general information 9f is this
property located in a federally
designated flood hazard Zone you have
that on your form
there and then there's another your form
is only two pages long and then there's
another sale form that I showed you that
has nothing on it and then there's
another one on the purchase and sales
agreement that says 15 number 15 due
diligence this agreement is contingent
upon buyer satisfactory review of the
following um sub comment G availability
and cost of flooding insurance so there
that doesn't mean on the okay so quickly
to to just re reinforce what you stated
specifically on the uh disclosure form
there are three options can you state
your names and what what makes you come
here sorry I'm sorry do you have any
Professional Standards I'm so very
excited to be here so your names and
what and who what do you do uh so my
name is Mark condo Demi I'm a licensed
professional engineer a licensed
professional surveyor I've also been
designated as what's called a certified
flood surveyor through the National
Society of professional surveyors okay
and I work specifically in the industry
of of flood the national flood insurance
program Etc Great um so the oh sorry and
uh my name is Bart MCD I'm the planning
director for the town New Market New
Hampshire and just for disclosure I
represent My Views not the towns
okay so uh just to reinforce what
representative said there are three op
options on the realtor disclosure yes no
or unknown and the vast majority of time
the unknown designation is selected
brief anecdote just to answer your
specific question about someone doing
their due diligence uh a single mother
um Cashes in her 401K looks to invest in
a home to uh upgrade herself and her
children um finds a beautiful spot after
engaging a realtor next to a a gorgeous
gurgling Brook the realtor uh helps her
through the disclosure process in which
the seller States unknown for flood um
the buyer for whatever reason um wanted
to do additional due diligence went to
her trusted insurance agent The Trusted
insurance agent looked up on a website
um through their insurance software as
to whether this property was in a
designated flood zone or not and they
came back with a certificate that
specifically said it wasn't so now two
people have reinforced the fact that it
was not and it turns out that they were
in error specifically because they said
unknown and then specifically because
the geoc coding for this property was
incorrect um this person again cashed in
her 401K did her due diligence made the
largest investment of her life to
upgrade her her for her children um as a
single mother and then the nightmare
began
because uh it turns out then then she
was in a designated flood zone when she
went to refinance it was found out that
she
was she wasn't able to afford the pre so
she did get financing well when she went
to get financing she found out pay cash
it was incorrect she would have had to
pay the uh the flood insurance which
then she wouldn't have been able to
afford that payment as a result she
could not leverage her investment to uh
pursue other economic opportunities um
and
had had significant trouble now when she
tried to take action against said
realtor and said other agency um sorry
no luck it was your own fault you were
supposed to do the due diligence um had
that Realtor simply looked at a map and
done their job and they would have
clearly seen clearly seen that this
property was in a designated uh flood
zone uh another brief anecdote again a
person a working family purchased a home
the property was in a designated flood
zone but it had been removed via a a
process called a letter of map Amendment
before they purchased the property um
they engaged again the seller had
engaged a realtor who again said unknown
in the sale and marketing of the
property um it was designated as not in
the flood zone because of this letter of
map Amendment now they purchased through
um a governmental entity this loan was
then transferred to a servicer who then
hired a vendor who made an error and
imposed flood
insurance the uh customer was then not
able to make their payments um thus
ruining their credit and they are now in
foreclosure as a result trying to fight
against this specific option this law
would specific Ally protect both of
these people as well as the commercial
landlord and investor that is doing
their due diligence but perhaps running
into incorrect information um maybe
perhaps an online vendor that is
providing uh uh work based on a geocoded
address that is not pinning or being
located in the correct area uh I as a
professional I literally deal with these
stories three to four times a week and
they are heartbreaking to listen to and
the simple remedy would be to as the
realtor is marketing the property as
they normally would to Simply remove the
unknown and have them specifically um
look at as to whether or not that
property is located in that mapped flood
zone or not and then if there is an
event you know then you as the homeowner
would simply disclose whether you are
aware as it says in the text um as to
whether you are aware or not and that
you would simply answer truthfully and
if you are not there when that event
happens and you weren't aware of it
happening you would be able to answer
truthfully that that you weren't aware
of that event firsthand and and that you
didn't
know representative M later um it's very
easy to access these government flood
zone uh Maps very easy but you're
telling me that there often wrong so the
maps themselves are not incorrect
now we have to look at this from you
know 30,000 fet okay a flood insurance
rate map is is printed and produced by
FEMA and it is adopted by the community
and what that flood insurance rate map
shows is it shows approximate risks it
will show areas that are included in a
special flood Hazard area that are
susceptible to a 1% store form discharge
it will show areas that are not included
as well so it's binary right in or out
but you have to look at it in the sense
that it is showing you risk and if you
are close in a close proximity to that
area you know certainly it is something
that you might want to look into more
pursue hire a professional to get more
information all of the mapping is
available um for free on the FEMA
website and you can download every
single flood insurance rate map in the
entire country country and every
territory for free and View and consume
it where the errors arise is when you're
doing a geocoded database search so for
instance uh if you've ever used a GPS um
and you've put an address sometimes that
address you've plugged into that GPS
will get you in the exact spot you want
to go sometimes it will get you very
close and sometimes it will take you
over the hill to Grandma's nowhere near
where you numbering was the opposite
I've seen that where the the address one
is on the south end of the road not the
North End of the Road and and so this
occurs quite frequently when you're
doing a geocoded search and if you are
looking to check the status of a
property that's in a flood zone and you
have an error in that geocoded search
where you're at the North End of the
Road as opposed to the South End of the
Road that could make a significant
difference obviously in the biggest
investment you may want to make in your
entire
life so when I look in here and it says
civil action so the only you're saying
this would resolve the problem it
doesn't resolve the problem because the
person still has to sue are they suing
the realator or are they suing the
seller of the property so let's say um
let's say you're you're a buyer you're
an investor um let's go to your story
let's take your one woman story that's
that's what I'm I'm I'm getting I'm
going to answer I'm going to answer your
question um so you you engage a realtor
and you want to know all of the due
diligence the realtor is going to do the
due diligence for you so the realtor
engages a third party to prepare this
flood report for you to is this a seller
realator or a buyer re realator uh could
be
either saying who who's the one that's
liable in this case I'm getting to that
in this case let's say it's the sell's
realtor so the Sellers realtor engages a
third party and they provide a report
and that report is not correct it is not
accurate okay so the liability based on
the way this bill is written would rest
solely on the vendor
that that Realtor relied on it would not
rest on the shoulders of the realtor
whereas if this language wasn't in there
it is very very possible that that
liability would rest solely on the
shoulders of the realtor and that's not
what we want obviously if you are a
professionally licensed realtor and you
are relying on third- party information
and you feel that that information that
you've paid for comes from a credible
source certainly there should be
liability on that third party that is
issuing that information and
guaranteeing it and that's what this
language
resolves and if there's no third
party uh if there's no third party and
someone made an error then obviously
they're liable for it sure who may I ask
question person checked off unknown that
unknown would go away with this bill no
I'm I'm saying if that if the if the
person checked
unknown under the current Cent form
there's that unknown how does that solve
this if that person said if they checked
unknown if there was no third party
analysis that this this the story your
story which is what I originally
visioned is because we saw a lot of
people just paying cash and then and
then financing afterwards so this person
bought the house paid cash the realer
got his commission the sale occurred and
then when they go to finance the bank
said oh by the way you're in a flood
zone
at that point if all they have is this
form that she's got here that says
unknown she's dumb out of luck right in
this specific case that buyer did go
back to the realtor that she engaged
said hey what the heck and the realtor
said I didn't know not my fault okay so
then so that means this bill would not
have solved her problem no this bill
would solve her problem because it would
have removed because the bill removes
the unknown checkbox so you only have a
a yes or a no and then in that case what
the what the realtor would have done is
they would have had to actually do some
due diligence that they were hired for
as a buyer's agent to provide that
knowledge and information to the buyer
yes or no okay they checked off no okay
and now is it who when I if that this
woman who is she going to sue is she
going to sue the realator or is she
going to sue the person who sold it who
who she has to prove lied when they said
no so in this in this specific case if
the realtor prepared that information
and looked at it then the realtor would
be liable if the realtor relied on a
third party that prepared Incorrect and
inaccurate information it would be that
third party that's liable we're assuming
that the realator be offering up this
Pur and sale agreement that has the
check no they're liable if that no is
wrong only if they didn't rely on a
third party only if they didn't rely
correct okay if they relied on third
party they're going to go Sue that third
part correct and this they didn't rely
on a third party they relied on the
person saying no there's no never been
any flooding problem okay now the
realtor is the one that's liable for
offering up this document and what is so
that this court can then get civil is is
going you then now suing she has to
sue the realtor of course I mean
misrepresentation of property by a
realtor is is a pretty significant issue
I just don't hear a lot of those cases
well there there are significant there
are significant cases where Realtors
will misrepresent property and that and
that is in that case that is that that
the
realtor um is is guilty simply because
that you have to then demonstrate
evidence not you don't have have to
demonstrate the evidence the realer knew
you have to demonstrate the evidence
that the owner the seller did know right
you have to prove that the seller did
know because your the ENT was the no was
checked so now to go to a court you have
to then prove that that somebody did
know that it had a flooding problem th
that's correct you would have to prove
that somebody did know that the property
was in a designated flood zone and
typically that would not even in the
flood zone you just had to know there
was flooding right wasn't this thing
this is all about flood zone well well
so the disclosure would be about whether
the property is located in a mapped
special flood Hazard area so FEMA prints
flood maps for each community and those
flood maps are publicly available and it
will show whether or not a structure or
property is located in that special
flood Hazard area it's simple to procure
the map to view it to look where the
property is and if the realtor
designates it
incorrectly they would certainly be
liable for that unless they relied on
that third party who would then be
liable for that may I ask a question Mr
chairman may I ask a question yes
represent Gibbs thank you
um uh thank you for taking my question
when you refer to a third party is that
third
party uh the company that the realtor
hired to do the GPS search or is that
third party the actual seller or could
it be either one it it could be either
one um it could also be let's say the
seller had financed uh through a lender
and the lender issued an incorrect
determination and the seller by no fault
of their own disclosed that they were
not in a a mapped flood zone and the
documentation that they received from
their Bank showed that they were not in
a mapped flood zone but they
were uh then that again the responsible
party for that would be the preparer of
that third party information the bank uh
no it wouldn't be the bank it would be
whoever the preparer of that third party
information is whether so probably we're
back to the seller uh no not the seller
again well but who who are we talking
about so the realtor they're suing the
realtor no no it wouldn't it wouldn't
necessarily be the realtor so who would
it be it would be disclosed on whatever
that report or document is so if you
purchase a piece of property and you get
a professional report on your septic
system professional report from whom
well if you get something on your septic
system you're going from whom okay wa
let's let's start back let's let's take
a step back a second this whole thing
about the third party person is sort of
a red herring because you're going to
that is really a plausible Deni that's a
deniability that makes the real not
liable at the end of the day if I
understand this correctly there your
this intention of this bill is the
realtor is responsible you're taking
away unknown you're deleting the unknown
which I I guess that I have to read that
in here you're deleting the unknown and
now the question is yes or no okay yes
there was flooding or no excuse me yes
it's within the flood zone or no it's
not in the flood zone that's a truth
simple black and white either it's in
the flood zone or not in the flood zone
and that the third party is just a you
know the defense for the realer if the
realtor said no and it turns out it was
yes but he said yes only because he got
bad advice he got bad from a third party
end of the day the real who's liable for
this yes no question followup question
Mr chairman yes thank you
um going back
to uh who who was
liable um suppose that
the
uh that the seller genuinely doesn't
know um and the seller is the only third
party if the seller was the seller of
the property the per that's right the
person who sell sells the property
there's no other professional report so
the realtor relied on the seller and
because it's not only I took a look at
the at the language um in in the
amendment and the language is not only
is it in a flood zone but was there
flood damage during the time that the
seller owned the property so suppose the
seller had rented out the property or
lent it to someone or for whatever
reason the seller was away when the
damage
occurred and the damage was minor enough
that the seller comes back and you know
it it's just looks like ordinary wear
and tear or something like that so the
seller genuinely doesn't know but the
damage occurred while the seller owned
the property in that case who is
liable correct me if I'm wrong Chris but
in my reading of the bill no one would
be because that seller would be
answering truthfully as it states in the
language that that he or she did not
know that there had been flood damage I
mean if they are answering truthfully
then then they wouldn't be held
to any liability for that okay and when
you refer to professional reports can
you give us an idea of who prepares
these professional reports sure there's
all kinds of um outfits out there that
prepare them from uh engineers and
surveyors to uh uh appraisers and
Realtors um there's an entire industry
of of companies that prepare flood zone
determinations for lenders and
homeowners and uh real estate
professionals um I know that there are
multiple real estate professionals
spefic specifically on the Sea Coast
that when they actually do list a
property will engage a third party to
have that flood report attached to their
listing and you'll see um a lot of times
and this is certainly with sophisticated
Realtors on the listing it'll say uh no
flood insurance required or flood
insurance required and on the uh
disclosure it will show a report from a
third party stating whether or not it is
or is not in or close maybe there's a
risk analysis uh along with that and
there are a multitude of companies that
provide this information and suppose
you're an ordinary person who doesn't
know anything about the the existence of
these companies could you then be liable
because you should have
known they're working with their realtor
the realtor should be telling them this
correct because typically it's the
realtor that is going to procure that
third party so for instance if there's a
boundary issue with a property and a
realtor suspects that perhaps there's a
boundary issue because the two neighbors
have been arguing um the realtor will
help to have that homeowner engage a
land surveyor to potentially resolve
that situation um you know the realtor
will help facilitate a lot of this stuff
does that mean the realtor then is going
to be liable for that boundary issue uh
no absolutely not certainly if there was
an error in doing that survey was would
be the surveyor's um accountability in
that that sense uh and it would apply
simply to a report or disclosure uh for
a realtor that again either refers or
relies on a third party to to prepare
that information and prepare that
you here's here's my question an
analogous somewhat analogous situation
let's say that there's lead paint and a
child's going to move into a house how
is that typically handled in um who'd be
responsible if family moved in didn't
know that there was lead paint there I
mean I know it's a I believe it's a
federal law that if a building is built
prior to 1973 you have to disclose that
there could be lead in in that property
um as far as liability beyond that I'm
I'm I'm not equipped to speak to that
there's a separate lead disclosure form
but most people when they're filling out
the disclosure form most sellers will
say I'm not aware of anything like that
and they have to sign that but you know
they it it's sort of fudge but just a
quick question if I'm the seller's uh
realtor and the seller doesn't really
know anything about that but but says no
on this question because there is no
unknown and I as a realtor uh go to to
the heo map get a map where it clearly
shows that this property is not in the
flood
zone to me that that's uh they've done
their due diligence
and they shouldn't be liable if uh you
know if a 500-year flood comes around
would that be correct that would
absolutely be correct and that's clearly
okay just I mean one of one of one of
the things you when you talk about lead
I mean right now in New Hampshire
statute there's only three
requirements um to dis that need to be
disclosed on a purchase and sale
agreement one is lead one is arnik and
one is on and what we would be doing
with this bill is we'd add flooding to
the to the same put that it puts it in
the same
RSA so going to go representative pcil
and then representative spear right well
I think I believe me I'm very sensitive
to this issue but you're saying that you
want a very specific map you want a
specific FEMA map you know signed and
dated so I think it might yes I
understand that but for you know
attached to your purchase and sale
there're what you're saying is that you
want the feea map not a third party the
it's disappointing that the insurance
company had incorrect information so I
think what what I'm struggling with here
is where is the specific requirement for
what map and detailing exactly when they
looked at the math and maybe have that
attached to the purchase and sale
otherwise this is so subjective I looked
here and it said no somebody else looked
here it said yes and I think that gets
very confusing and I don't want people
suing each other because that will not
resolve the problem so if you're saying
I want a specific government issued map
that is online we need dated and
attached to the purchase and sale and
it's up to the realtor to do that that's
a different story but not every home is
sold by a realtor so I want to make sure
that
we're solving solving this issue in in
the best possible way so that there are
no subsequent lawsuits I I I agree with
you completely and and I believe this
bill does that um it does not
specifically State you you have to have
a specific flood map it says you have to
disclose it says you have to disclose
whether you are located in or outside of
a mapped special flood Hazard
area well the it's it's not necessarily
the data of the mapping that's the
problem certainly its geocoded location
problem on on a on an online site
correct because it's a geocoded error
it's pulling from a different that's
right it's pulling from a different
database what exactly what what are you
supposed to do I mean would you make a
real estate investment based on
something you know now is is incorrect
wouldn't you want wouldn't you want a a
licensed regulated professional to help
guide you through the process to make
sure you're getting the that's why I'm
hiring a realtor for 6% of the selling
want and now I have to have another
engineer try to figure this out it's
very
confusing but then would you want that
Realtor to check
unknown certainly would want a
definitive
answer yes because then I would be able
to pursue it further so if they check
yes no or unknown it's still you're
subject to the data that is available
sure but again it's not the FEMA data
that is that is incorrect it is the
geocoded data you would be using what
how am I suppos so I want to go a
different direction with this bill okay
so at the end of the day we have let
alone the he say she say or who's
responsible going on and on um the
question and we were just discussing it
here is that when someone signs that
purchase sale
agreement they're signing it based upon
all the information is on there the
question would be is could we add a box
at the bottom where the person
signs and
says that they have done the homework to
find out whether it's in the blood flood
zone or not in other words put the
responsibility on the buyer to do to
make sure they got the right study they
got the right thing we don't instead of
in that way we're not creating Court Li
me anything that creates litigation is
messy in my mind okay that if we put it
on the responsibility of the buyer that
they had done the proper search they
have got the right information if they
got misinformation from somebody then
they can sue that person for the
misinformation because that they thought
they got it but that rather than getting
realer and seller and getting all that
confusion in there let's just put an
onus on the buyer that they tell us
whether they have done the due diligence
on one the flood zone or
not and okay now this is just a concept
that I'm putting out now obviously we're
not going to solve this problem today
this bill is not going to get solved
today we can C be taking this up in
subcommittee again next Tuesday okay but
we're just throwing out some other you
know other ways to do it to simplify
this bill because I mean first of all
this whole thing with the tenant thing
in my mind you got to take that out I
mean we're you know landlord tenant
that's a whole another nightmare that we
certainly don't want to get get involved
in this bill um I think that's we want
to keep it simple this is about a real
estate transaction and whether the
responsibility for some of us is is
buyer beware but the other is saying is
that to to expect to get good
information out of a seller or the
realator of the seller or the third
party consultant of the seller just
makes it like a nightmare representative
spear
I thank you I bought my house 20 years
ago not that long ago I received no
notification about radon I received I
certainly never received anything like
this I got nothing What state were you
here just right in nation when you
bought the property yeah oh what did I
live I came out of New York okay New
York does a very different thing than
what we do here so you never saw one of
these never saw one of these never knew
anything about radon the only way I
found out about radon is a neighbor came
to me and said did your real estate
agent tell you about radon and I said I
don't even know what that is and then I
found out and we had the radon thing in
so you've never seen this agreement
before never have seen it before okay so
now I can understand by or beware I
understand that notion but I resent the
fact that they not responsible to tell
us anything and I I I don't feel good
about that at
all I'm I'm an engineer so I knew that
there were things that I had to get take
care of and I knew I had certain
responsibilities but not everybody does
know that and I think it behooves us to
make these real estate agents take some
level of responsibility for giving us
some level of information cuz I never
saw anything like this before well
obviously you you had a private sale
what did you sign a purchase sale
agreement you know you know what the
purchase sale agreement is versus the
deed no okay represent as a real estate
agent this bill is much simpler than
people are making it out to be that's
number one number two uh it's the seller
who initiates the disclosure now the
buyer has to accept that but all the
seller has to do in my mind
in in conjunction with their selling
broker is find out whether the place is
in a flood zone now think if the buyer
wants to go out and hire a third party
that's that's fine but but if I'm
the the seller's agent I'm going to tell
the seller we're going to look at the uh
the FEMA flood map and there it says is
that you're not in a flood zone you
you've done it all if it says you are in
a flood zone you're going to have to
disclose it simple as that it's not that
complicated it really
isn't and and I think that selllers need
to be pushed more into being a little
bit more honest I read too many of these
disclosures they I don't know I don't
know if we've ever had any problem there
they're just and they get away with it
so this this representa gives
legislators speak first thank you uh the
bill says more than that it doesn't say
just is it in a flood zone which might
be at least relatively easy to find out
it also says has there been any flood
damage and that's where I think you run
into the problems that I mentioned
before the am took some of that out the
amendment took some of that out the
amendment that we have in front of
us it it didn't look like that but I
could be wrong if if the amendment took
some of that out that would be better
thank you okay yes
sir yeah you have to turn the mic on
there we go it's on um so I think this
goes beyond just the sale the
transaction too um we'll say right when
the what this bill would do also would
bring people to the town because town
has additional regulations for flood
plane management so this would be an
opportunity to have that dialogue with
said seller or buyer say what you can
and cannot do with your property after
you buy it so that's more information
that's more opportunity to get out of
that information uh the buyer because
what educate them about all the zoning
ordinances in the community especially
in the flood
because right not not all the not all
the ores but specifically related to we
would tell them about that obviously but
the flood plane um I can tell New Market
there's only specific areas in town
where you can build in a flood plane um
and other areas it's prohibited you
can't expand so again we're giving more
information to people who are making a
huge
investment so then that's opportunity to
have that dialogue so this bill would do
this
I don't see that but
okay this build has put is is is gives
people a false sense of repr you just
made it what you kept saying is this
person made a mistake this people
screwed up these people had the wrong
address this happen this happened okay
all does if you did that then everyone
who buys this think that that they're
all set they're think they're all
protected they don't have a flood
problem because that person checked off
the box and they were wrong what's wrong
with that no you're I mean you know
representative U melier he he summarized
it best I mean it's not that complicated
what we're talking about is having a
seller share information about their
property withy not be correct and that's
the seller's responsibility to make sure
it's correct whole problem you didn't
solve anything you just told us all the
time that these people had the wrong
address or the wrong GPS location that
the company and oh well it's okay they
could just that other company who's in a
better situation to resolve that issue
situation the seller or the buyer the
seller who knows the property and where
the property is located or the buyer who
doesn't know that information I'm saying
the buyer has an obligation to do
diligence and I'm not disagreeing with
you but I have I'm also saying that the
seller has an obligation to share all
the information they have about the
property to the buyer before they they
they complete that transaction we we
went through this when we you noticed of
that list what was anybody ever died or
anybody had AIDS in that house I mean we
went through the same whole debate and
you go back and read those paragraphs
and see what we did okay at the end of
the day we all know that you're not
going to go and tell the full story
you're not going to tell everybody you
know the dirty little details of what
happened in that house you're trying to
sell it you know but you don't want to
sell a problem no no see but you've got
yeah that's why selling it so why don't
you just say I'm just going to Discount
this price $100,000 because I know full
well that you're going to flood out
tomorrow I have a
question yeah I'm going to oppose this
to the chair so in the scenario with
this single woman who was given false
information and it blew up her whole
investment do you think that she was
solely responsible for that when she got
false information that nobody should be
liable here that she screwed up
did did she get the false the false
information should she be holding the
bag cuz somebody else screwed up I think
that if that if you're buying a house in
Hampton and if you don't know to check
whether that property is in a flood
plane or that what is the history of
that property then I do think you're
being irresponsible okay but I I follow
up follow up I have I having a scenario
I have friends who bought a property
along a river and they were stupid okay
they didn't they didn't I mean I'm being
totally honest they were stupid they did
not find out that the freaking house was
going to float away at some point s
River and so the fact that they were
dumb should they be hold up the whole
bag or did the realtor have some and the
seller have some responsibility to tell
these dumb
people killing me and and and there's a
lot of other places tell somebody
they're dumb
they're not listening they're they're
away for this the winter I'd like to
call call the question excuse me there's
one one comment that I I have to make I
came from out of state to move here I
didn't even know there was such a thing
is right on I never would have looked
for it if you're coming from I don't
know New Mexico you might not think
about flooding you you just don't know
and I don't consider myself on the dumb
list but maybe I am I didn't know if I
bought a house anywhere along the coast
okay any town along the coast it's not
just on the coast flooding I look at the
if you're buying a house along the coast
you have to consider flooding not fire
you're smarter than the aage repres if
you look at the FEMA map it's not just
the coast I don't disagree that anybody
that's buying a home in in Hampton
should ask the question because you're
close to the marsh but what about the
person that buys a home in Claremont or
New Market I mean they're they're far
away from the ocean they get affected by
right on the Connecticut River and the
house could float down the river Mr
chairman would you believe 71% of the
planet is covered in
water okay what we're going to do is
we're going to take this up on Tuesday
we'll reschedule this bill for Tuesday
and and that gives everybody the whole
weekend to think about how do we how do
we do this bill right but I can tell you
right out of the block
the landlord tenant thing is not uh
you're if you insist on trying to keep
that in this bill then that I there's no
way in the world I can find a compromise
for you that that just opens more caner
worms that's a whole different set of
you know issues and and I'm sorry we
can't you know you the purchase sale
agreement has nothing to do with
landlord tenant it's a totally different
agreement and and we've excluded we
we've we've B we've we've separated that
I mean the amendment the original Bill
the the bill that was originally filed I
thought I saw it in the amendment the
the bill that was filed originally was
drafted incorrectly it lumped the
renters and and purchasers together in
the the first amendment I shared with
you and this amendment that you have now
we've separated that and all that we are
asking is that a flood disclosure be
included in the lease agreement okay so
am I looking at the correct Amendment
1122 1122 why do I see things in here
that says tenant because we're still we
still think that disclosing the same
information about flood risk to a tenant
is appropriate if I'm just saying I
can't I would not I can't that's a
non-starter for me I and I I respect
that but I I would also say that it it
it it's important because there have
been situations where tenants have
entered into a lease they've gone to bed
and it's rained overnight and they've
woken up and the parking lot's flooded
and their car is underwater y or the
house is has molden okay all right so
just a question for you and and by the
way thank you everybody for your your
time and attention to this I I I really
appreciate it and the and the good
spirited discussion um the the meeting
on Tuesday is that an executive session
or would that be just a continuation
continuation I don't know if you
remember we don't go to when we go to
executive committee we've the
subcommittee has already determined what
we're going to do with this bill okay so
but on Tuesday you're going to exec
we're going to subcommittee subcommittee
we would execute on Wednesday okay would
you like us to to come back on Tuesday
or would you prefer oh you're absolutely
invited to do it great what time is that
and I would tell you if you come back
with an amendment that says that it's a
check a box if you don't like the you
know the different three different
questions okay which is already in
statute right if you want to come back
with it at the at the end of the sign
where the person signs and they checked
off a box that they they have done due
diligence to find out whether there's
flooding and whether they they've
checked the federal flood zone and that
they're confident that they got a good
report okay if you come in with anything
you know but you know and if you come in
with tenant I mean I no I I I'm I'm just
trying to keep it simple get to the
point that you want to make and whose
responsibility at the end of the day no
one should be buying a property that's
going to
flood nobody should be buying that and
if they are buying it I sure hope they
got a good discount to build up put to
lift the house up and put it on stilts
which is what I get to see in my summer
community that every house that sells
down in mamic at Rhode Island is now
built with stilts
right what's
up just to to really quickly address
that um technically everyone is in a
flood zone it just has to do with your
risk and if you were to drive down
through alad in 2005 you would see
houses on the side of a mountain that
were literally washed away by flooding
that weren't in designated that's not a
good example because that was a man-made
cause that was a cber that got clogged
and no no it wasn't it was it was a
natural it was it was aad it was a super
discharge there was a a higher than
normal amount of rain discharge and it
created flooding like people had never
seen and there were literally houses a
different allstead flood than I know of
the one I know of where someone died was
because of a cver there were two floods
was one in 2005 and one in 2007 both of
them occurred in
allad right buildings that were affected
were literally on the sides of mountains
and you know all right all set could I
just say one last thing yes um to to
representative portelli's point I mean
about drainage I I I I get it I mean
that's a that that is an issue um and I
I I don't think it's an issue we want to
try to address in this specific bill I
think that's another issue um so I just
I didn't want to dismiss it as not
important I just think it's um it's a
diff it's a little bit different than
than flood risk but you might want to
think about that at some point that
might to your point why don't we we got
to go when representative hunt de
support bill will add that I'm supposed
to go down to finance and Salvage
marijuana so we got to keep going here
oh let's keep it here okay all right 149
establishing a short-term rental
registry um at this point uh we we had
two short-term uh bills the um neither
the realators nor nor Municipal
Association wants me to go anywhere near
trying to solve this problem at this
point this year so um we either itl it
or or interim study it but this the next
two we we cannot at this point um
there's too much going on too much
litigation going on right now and they
just don't want us to try to solve it um
make a motion that we itl both these
bills okay we'll take one at a time okay
1498 itl representative macul by
representative hunt any discussion on
the motion seeing none all those in
favor raise our hand one two three four
five six
okay uh 1635 representative mular second
by represent moves
itl
any discussion on the motion seeing none
all those in favor raise your right hand
1 two 3 4
56 okay um repealing the requirement to
register Farmers Market at a trade
bill it it up perfect okay
representative uh parti is not on this
okay represent uh who would like to make
oh I'll just make the motion okay
represent hunt
moves uh
TL okay uh representative spear second
by motion of any to legislate all those
in favor raise your right hand 1 2 3
four five six okay 1159 relative to
toilet facilities provided by
establishments what what's what was the
story with this
bill don't we have a a public works
effort that a building Cod didn't we
already pass a bill on this subject
matter we we delayed one because of uh
the building codes right we and so they
established some building codes so why
are we dealing with this
again I remember that that is correct I
think this is an itl itl i okay I
thought it was interim study says same
as
1173 yeah this bill is similar to a
Senate Bill a bill that we already
passed that was the bill we passed last
so it should be on to the Senate that's
right you don't yeah so okay so we can
just itl this one y
okay unless we want an interim study in
case the Senate kills that one oh no it
so Mike do you know anything about that
building code for restaurants that
inside how many
bathrooms
yeah
right
right okay great itl representative
hunt represent spear okay okay itl all
those in favor raise your
hand by six okay last but not least
relative to food service at Ben
breakfast now I know why you're still
here
Mike okay Chris did you get get a print
Chris okay so this is another issue
I I spoke to the
department and uh begged them to fix
this problem so that we can not have to
deal with this bill but so um hopefully
this solves the issue I'm not sure the
um
right okay perfect all right so you'll
look on two sides she's bold faed what
you need to know because this turns out
to be a 14 page
rules not five
page okay so the D you can see now that
what how we have the definition who's a
bed and
breakfast and then uh over on you can
lick your finger I don't care and then
BB is what a snack is is now allowed so
we took out if you remember me before
that we had the discuss the the rule was
going to be um you know no more than six
snack six times a a month and and uh uh
but now we're we're getting focused in
on exactly what is it uh that there
is is allowed to be
made
so wasn't there a discussion
about I'm sorry who who I'm sorry I have
some notes that say that we would that
where meals are to take out snacks and
the definitions of of of what is
appropriate would be left to rules
correct so do you want to come in and
explain to her how this works so because
uh I think the key the key word that I
noticed when I looked at this was U
reheating commercially made food so that
stofers that would be okay sure hi I'm
Abby Rogers I'm the legislative leis on
for the division of Public Health
Services um I just wanted to share that
the Department was made aware of
Representative Lehman's concern on
Outreach to the department before I
guess it was last session on this issue
and so we preemptively had our rules
open so when you see that L that very
long rule this is only a portion of that
so what we changed in the role to
accommodate um on behalf of his
constituent who is a a owner of a bed
and breakfast was to expand the
definition of bed and breakfast uh to um
allow the service of a snack for late
arriving guests who may come late to the
bed and breakfast and they missed the
breakfast piece um also adding a
definition of snack in the rule so
that's clear so that's what we did in
the rules and the rules uh passed uh
Jael car on February
16th okay so you want to answer my
question reheating commercially made
food right so does that mean I can
reheat a stoer meal because they took it
out of the freezer and microwaved it can
that be pered yes that means that it's
not prepared at the bread and bed and
breakfast in definition of something
that just needs to be reheated and not
prepared there or cooked in the bed and
breakfast facility that's my
understanding okay so it no oh yeah the
bill yeah the itl yes yeah right
okay uh would that affect um PL and
thank you yeah um Mr chair and thank you
for being here today sure um would this
apply it says bed and breakfast would
that apply to an BNB type
or no okay no so under 143 A9 that's our
rule making for bed and breakfast
there's a specific license for licensure
for
that thank you sure okay represent Cole
was there a discussion between a home
kitchen versus a commercial kitchen
about this bill too so we we in the
conversation what we're talking about is
how a bed and breakfast if they wanted
to have have meals they would then have
to be required to put in a commercial
kitchen so if they're not if in this
case this particular person that you
know they he was going on how how great
her kitchen is but it didn't it it
failed in septic and in sinks I think
yes right didn't have enough sinks and
didn't have the right septic and so
therefore you know that that did they
would have to spend
20 grand to upgrade their septic system
and upgrade to to be able to be a
restaurant or have a restaurant quality
commercial quality kitchen if they if
the definitions have been squared away
in rules yes we don't really need this
anymore that is correct okay okay
so representative spear second by
representative hunt moves in expedient
to
legislate any discussion on the
motion see none all those in favor raise
your hand
5 who's
on I know so I'm not why not because
colear and oh I see why was I thinking
that you were voting before okay all
right one two three four five
six okay
great so in the mshot we only had one
bill that
unresolvable
e
for